I have removed my shirt because the body
made me warm come back puppies puppies
puppies puppies
come here little or ask Oh
little rascal my favorite part about
filming The Maze Runner movies was the
family oh my God he's shaking the family
that was made on set we all really had
an amazing time making these movies and
they're constantly falling and they're
constantly a joy to do which is super
rare do you need me to like sit up if I
pick a character I'd say Chuck cuz he
was he was like it's like a drink up
he's like a dog he's man's best friend
just like these dogs are my best friends
come here anytime on set with Tyler it
was always the best team Wolfe is like a
second home to me and Tyler's like a
brother the puppies I'm kidding they're
no puppies in the movie this film this
last movie answers all the questions
that fans and people have seen the first
two you may have so well it's finally
all gonna be wrapped up and you're
finally gonna be not confused anymore if
I were to give my younger self one piece
of advice it would be to not be so shy
lean into nerves or even if it
especially if it's involves something
that you know you genuinely enjoy don't
let fear and kind of nerves or shyness
keep you away from doing it because it
almost kept me away from
but not the puppy cocker spaniel cuz
that was my dog growing up I gotta take
this off I'm getting hot tyler posey
again or anyone on my team of cast mates
or any one of my Maze Runner cast mates
one of the biggest part of those things
ending is realized and you you know you
don't know when you're gonna work with
these guys again so and it would I would
jump at the chance to always stay
grounded and just be you always and
normal and just to value your roots and
your friends it's easy to get caught up
in the industry or in Hollywood or
whatever if you're young active but no
it's important oh my god can we zoom in
on that there was some Butthead nuzzling
going on knows what back into his book
[Music]
none of them I made a music video one
time it haha are we gaining this oh no
was that too much for you first video I
ever posted to my channel was this
little music video that me and my best
friends from New Jersey made and that
was like how I started my channel cuz
then my friend was like oh you should
put this on YouTube and I was like
what's YouTube and then I just made an
account put that video up there and then
that became my youtube channel no I
think they probably had a few weeks and
broke up or something she's complicated
that one is yeah yeah they're destined
to be together
they love that sandbag
[Music]
you know not as often as we'd like I
think it's it's tough when you're trying
to see people you know in the industry
so it's tough everyone is always away or
traveling it's rare to be in the same
place at one time but given all that I'd
say I've seen them pretty often I see
Tyler all the time all the major movies
always taught me something as an actor
and a person go ahead venture out yes
No what was the question you always
trying to get your legs and shape a
little bit cuz you're running major um
next question
I don't know if you can call what I did
on new girl singing and yeah I would
love to be in a musical I don't think
I'd ever be allowed to be in one because
it's I can't sing I was what oh if I
wasn't here if I wasn't it active
guys come on the grand finale
all three puppies I'd work with little
puppies
oh I need three arms
[Music]